أتذكر عندما حدثت هذه الصورة ، كان
الجميع يفعلها ، كانت نوعاً ما
لحظة وانتشرت بسرعة إلى أي مدى
تعتقد وفقدت وظيفتك بسبب
ذلك ولكن بعد ذلك أصبح من المهم في
حملتك إلى أي مدى تعتقد أنها
ساعدتك نعم  وأشكرك جزيل الشكر
لاستضافتي آرون الليلة ، فأنا
أقدر
ذلك حقًا ، ولا شك في أن تلك الصورة وأنا
طردني ظلماً
من وظيفتي في العمل ، أطلقوا
رغبتي في أن أصبح ناشطًا
سياسيًا في ذلك اليوم الذي طردت منه.
عدت إلى المنزل وقمت بالتسجيل للعمل في
صناديق الاقتراع خلال فترة الولاية في عام
2017 وأنت تعرف أنني لا أعرف أنها
ساعدت في التعرف على اسمي في
مجتمعي ، فأنا نشط جدًا في
مجتمعي ، لكنه بالتأكيد بدأ
نشاطي.  عندما تنظر إلى الأمر مرة أخرى
ومدى انتشاره ، تشعر بأي
ندم حول كيفية ظهور الرسالة
أو كيف أظهرت
غضبك على الرئيس
ومكتب الرئيس ، فأنا حقًا لا أشعر
بأي ندم على  ص لذكر
رأيي في ذلك اليوم لا على الإطلاق ، أعني أن
الأشياء كانت كل شيء اعتقدنا أنه
يمكن أن يحدث بشكل خاطئ كان يسير على نحو خاطئ في ذلك
الوقت ، أعني الخطاب البغيض أنك
تعرف الانتقادات
والتمييز ضد المهاجرين ،
كل شيء اعتقدنا أنه يمكن أن يفسد
كان سيئًا في ذلك الوقت وأصبح الأمر
يزداد سوءًا في الحقيقة لا ، فأنا لا أشعر
بأي ندم على ذلك